J.P Sears the most spiritual man on the
planet has officially changed his mind
about God and Christianity if you're not
familiar with JP he runs the YouTube
channel awaken with JP I first saw him
years ago in one of his Ultra spiritual
life videos where he plays a parody of a
spiritual Wellness Guru I'm JP Sears I'm
ultra-spiritual and I'm going to teach
you how to be ultra spiritual today the
reason why I like to do yoga photo
shoots is it's probably the most
effective way for me to bring love and
light into the world if you accepted
organic food into your life
what I've been having life-changing
results since I learned how to get
offended I love using essential oils as
alternative remedies for common ailments
like colds and the flu instead of using
remedies that actually work back then I
couldn't tell what he really believed
because he was playing a character but
it turns out that JP was or maybe still
is a wellness Guru a spiritual life
coach that's how he started on YouTube
he was making self-help and wellness
videos but he eventually posted some
videos that were making fun of
ultra-spiritual people who go overboard
and become judgmental and condescending
toward anyone who isn't as Ultra
spiritual as they are and those videos
took off so he's stuck with that
approach more recently JP was making
videos about lockdowns and mandates so
he seemed like a comedic conservative
cultural commentator this week however
he posted a video titled I changed my
mind about God here's why but again he
plays a character in a lot of videos so
I didn't know if it was going to be a
serious video or not fortunately he said
this early on and also quick disclaimer
this video is not intended to be a
comedy video and if that offends you
pray about it now when someone starts
talking about praying and going to
church Christians are happy for him but
we don't run around like the dawa gangs
pretending that someone converting or
saying something nice about our religion
is some kind of proof that our religion
is true when the dawa gangs get a
convert they shout from the rooftops you
see so and so converted this is the
proof it's the proof that our religion
is true
really what about all the people who
leave your religion and become
Christians or atheists what about that
that's no proof at all
fact is people change their minds all
the time people changing their minds
doesn't prove much so I'm not terribly
interested in commenting on the mere
fact that someone changed his mind about
God and Christianity but I am interested
in a person's reasons for changing his
mind when someone explains why he
changed his mind we can ask two
important questions one are they good
reasons and two are they reasons that
could be shared by other people and as I
watched JP's video I was thinking this
is something that a lot of people are
about to go through
so let's watch some clips from JP's
video about God and Christianity because
we're going to be hearing a very similar
story over and over and over again in
the near future
JP Begins by explaining what he used to
think about Christianity
I used to have a lot of judgment about
religion and Christianity thinking like
ah it's not bad but it's like dude
that's so outdated and like why are you
religious when you could be spiritual
religion is like phone books overhead
projectors Blockbuster Video dial up
internet Myspace it's old and outdated I
became very inundated in the spiritual
movement so like spirituality not
religion be spiritual not religious said
every Hollywood actor ever
due to the religious connotations JP
didn't even like using the word god
I used to have Shame about saying the
word God you know back when I thought
like dude I'm spiritual I'm so cool I
used to have Shame about using the word
God and instead I'd say oh the universe
and just create different names he
thought that certain religious practices
like prayer may have a positive impact
on people but not because people are
actually talking to God I used to think
well prayer is probably a good thing
it'll maybe give you a more positive
mood but I didn't truly believe in the
power of prayer where people are
directly asking God for God's support
and then receiving that support from God
and when he thought of religion he
thought of wars and Scandals I would
look at all the scandals that have
happened in the name of religion I mean
so many wars have been fought based on
religion based on God so I would kind of
throw the baby out with the bathwater
like oh dude that dirty bath water yeah
that's what Christianity is screw that
if that's what God is screw that but JP
says he learned a lot from his pursuit
of spirituality I got a lot of benefit
from spiritual teachings like different
teachers different books different
philosophies obviously if you want to be
on The Cutting Edge of spiritual
awesomeness you don't want anything to
do with that old VHS cassette we call
Christianity
but when I look back I can see I was
excluding some amazing traditional
Christian values beliefs of God and ways
of connecting with God that I now really
value no school like the old school am I
right
so what happened JP over the past three
years I've found myself accidentally
getting more Christian like without even
intentionally trying like setting out on
a mission like I want to become more
Christian it's just been effortlessly
happening for me he's been adopting more
Christian values and beliefs and
practices over the past few years
without intending to do so and he
noticed that he's not alone now I don't
think I'm unique there because I've seen
a lot of people and I've heard a lot of
people telling me similar stories which
raises an obvious question
so I asked the question
why are people getting more Christian
without even trying is it because of
that Jesus Revolution movie
here's what I believe to be true about
that the presence of evil and Satan that
evil emanates from has never been more
obvious true Evil all around
evil isn't hiding anymore it's coming at
us through authoritarianism movements
people groups companies governments yes
lots of evil what's your point
if you're not someone who's willing to
propagate evil then there's a natural
occurrence that happens when you're in
the presence of evil you polarize to The
Other Extreme the presence of evil makes
you lean away then therefore what
direction are you leaning towards
but that would be the direction of God
seeing the presence of evil that's why
I've just accidentally been getting more
Christian why so many other people are
interesting people are becoming more
Christian without realizing it because
they're seeing so much evil and they're
trying to get away from the evil I think
the evil that's in this world is doing a
great service of driving a lot of people
to find God in ways that they previously
hadn't so even though evil is bad but
evil can lead to a positive outcome
and also specifically we could say hey
there is an attempt to bring communism
all over the world sounds like someone
doesn't like communism and there's a
reason why Communists have their number
one objective to disconnect people from
God with full-on Communism they ban
religion why is that why would
Communists have a problem with religion
because they don't want people having
faith in a real higher power if you get
people to disconnect from the teachings
of God and the ways of God the belief in
God those communists
get to be your higher power
indeed as Francis Schaefer once put it
no totalitarian Authority nor
authoritarian State can tolerate those
who have an absolute by which to judge
that state and its actions an
authoritarian State can't tolerate a
higher authority than the state so those
who want an authoritarian State have to
destroy belief in a higher authority
all right JP is reacting to evil in its
various forms where is he at now I now
look at traditional Christian values
with a lot of respect and reverence and
I'm integrating those more into my life
Christian values around Family First
Christian values around faith in God and
I now believe that the power of prayer
is the most important thing you and I
can do I will make no claims that I'm
the world's best Christian or most
devoted Christian but I'm looking at
these Christian values and they make way
more sense to me now than they
previously did what about your problem
saying the word god JP
so I'm delighted to say now I have not
only no shame about saying God but I
actually have joy in saying God
and what about your view of church
scandals and such now I have a much more
mature look where I do believe evil goes
wherever it can the devil masquerades as
an angel of Light so if the devil wants
to control people a good way for the
devil to do that is to find people where
they're trying to find God I think we
need discernment I will discern evil
from churches discern evil from God
that's a start
and get this right now I think we're at
a time of spiritual warfare you think we
look at what's going on in the world
conflict between different nations
division all over the place we want to
teach this to your kids it's like ah you
seem kind of satanic pretty creepy even
though we see these literal things
playing out at the physical level I
think what we're seeing is symptoms of
what's happening at more of a
metaphysical level
very interesting the conflicts we see
around us are a symptom of a deeper
spiritual and metaphysical conflict in a
time of spiritual warfare what's on the
line is you and I our souls our children
one side wants to control us the other
side wants to free us there's an
underlying spiritual war going on and
it's something that we can't ignore
because everything we love is at stake
and I think what we do in our day-to-day
lives our actions our thoughts our words
is determining which side of the
spiritual warfare we're fighting on so
there's a spiritual war
everything is on the line we're all
already involved because everything we
do is supporting one side or the other
so we need to make sure we're on the
right side
see why I said I'm far more interested
in a person's reasons for changing his
mind than in the mere fact that a person
changed his mind
JP is on an amazing journey I'm glad
he's including us in that journey by
sharing what's been happening in his
life if you'd like to watch his full
discussion about God and Christianity
his video is about 25 minutes long the
link is in the description box
May the Risen Lord bless many of his
viewers
to awaken with JP
[Music]